nueva jornada electoral Y esta es la más
clara imagen de la apatía frente a las
Quintas elecciones que celebra Israel
desde 2019
cruzan la línea roja Porque es la quinta
vez que vamos a votar y una y otra vez
siento que a veces es como si
estuviéramos Enredados en esta forma de
que los políticos juegan con todas las
cartas que tienen y al final los
perjudicados somos nosotros
los israelíes votan en los comicios
nacionales con la esperanza de romper el
estancamiento político que ha paralizado
el país entre la comunidad árabe el 17%
del electorado se mostraban partidarios
de acudir a las urnas con el fin de
frenar a la extrema derecha
siempre voto voto en todas las
elecciones debemos votar si no votas la
derecha gana queremos detener a los
extremistas de extrema derechos
sionista va en vivir está ganando
terreno entre el electorado más
conservador hemos venido aquí para
recordar a todo el mundo a nuestro
querido pueblo lo más fundamental que
por desgracia se ha olvidado un poco en
los últimos años y es la identidad judía
recuperar el carácter judío del Estado
también en el Primer Ministro benjamine
tanyaju Busca la relelección apelando al
voto judío
representamos al público cuidaremos de
todos los ciudadanos de Israel de la
forma tradicional judía que hemos estado
siguiendo durante miles de años
sin ningún partido logra 61 de los
escaños en el parlamento el Primer
Ministro interino yait lapid conservará
el título de Primer Ministro de
transición por otros seis meses
creo en tratar de crear una coalición
que sea más representativa en todo el
país y no una corriente o pensamiento
específico y creo que la coalición
actual es bastante buena en eso era como
derechista izquierdista religiosos y no
religiosos
casi siete millones de israelíes están
llamados a las urnas y parece que la
posibilidad de una sexta vuelta
electoral está en la mente de